(musique et applaudissements)
- Du haut de ses 2 mètres,
à 53 ans, John Fetterman
espère devenir le futur sénateur
démocrate de la Pennsylvanie.
(applaudntntntnts)
Natif de la région,
le lieutenant gouverneur devance
de peu son rival républicain.
Ses partisans sont en liesse,
l'ambiance est électrique.
Mais sa campagne bat de l'aile,
car ses problèmes de santé
font sans cesse la une.
D'emblée, il aborde le sujet.
"Parlons de l'éléphant
dans la pièce, dit-il.
J'ai récemment eu un AVC.
Les seuls problèmes
que j'ai sont auditifs",
assure-t-il à ses partisans.
"Parfois, j' u u u un mot,
dit-il, ou j'utilise
deux mots qui n'existent pas."
Rien pour apaiser le camp
démocrate, déjà inquiet.
Son rival républicain,
Memet Oz, a vu sa cote
remonts s s s qu'il a recu
le soutien de Donald Trump.
- Dr. Oz is a man who truly
believes in the megamovement...
- Il ne manque pas de
rappeler l'état de santé
de son adversaire.
"Soit John Fetterman est
en santé, dit-il, et évite
les questions sur la gauche
radicale ou il est trop malade
pour participer à un débat."
(en anglais)
- Lundi matin, à 8 h,
ce chirurgien et personnalité
publique fait campagne
dans un restaurant ferméenenene.
- You're the biggest,
most powerful voice...
- Il a le verbe facile et,
à 62 ans, il tente de ravir
le vote des indécis.
- Nothing will get in our way!
- "Les prix montent et
on continue de dépenser",
dit ce partisan républicain.
"Il faut augmenter l'offre
et déréglementer le marché."
"C'est un libre penseur, Oz,
dit-il, et il a bien réussi
dans la vie."l l l l va trouvern
de réduire les coûts."
"C'est difficile
pour une famille moyenne
de mettre de la nourriture
sur la table", dit-elle.
L'augmentation du coût
de la vie inquiète
et Dr. Oz, comme on l'appelle
ici, l'a bien compris.
Sur Tik Tok, le chirurgien
fait ses courses et s'insurg
contre la flambée des prix.
"20 $ pour des crudités,
dit-il, et sans la tequila,
c'est scandaleux."
(en anglais)Pour les démocratest
l'élection de la dernière chance
pour sauver la déme,e,e,e,
rien de moins.
La démocratie est en état de
siège, dit-elle.
Selon le washington post,
291 candidats républicains
aux élections de mi-mandats
ne recsesesesent toujours pas
les élections de 2020.
"Il est possible qu'on ne puisse
plus voir d'élections libres
aux États-Unis", dit-il.
Il y a la démocratie
puis le droit à l'avortement
qui est en jeu.
Personne ne peut me dire quoi
faire avec mon corps dit-elle
Je défendrai toujours le droit
à l'avortement dit-il et relance
son rival sur la question.
La question n'est même pas
abordée dans le camp républicain
La vie commence à la conception
dit jane tout bonnement
Ici on croit à la pilule miracle
du Dr Oz.
Après l'inflation, il va régler
les problèmes de la criminalité
et de drogue nous dit-on.
Comment? on ne sait pa
mais il convainc.
"Combien d'entre vous ont peur
chchchcher la nuit?", dit-il.
Ça n'arrivait pas il y a deux,
trois ans."
L'ombre de Donald Trump plane
toujours sur cette campagne
Dr Oz va combattre la
criminalité dit il il va a
"Dr Oz va combattre la
poursuivre tous les revendeurs
de drogue.utututut sauver
l'Amérique."
La bataille est serrée.
Une fois de plus, le pays est
polarisé sur des questions
fondamentales.
Les deux partis veulent
sauver l'Amérique,
mais pas de la même façon.
Azeb, les élections de
mi-mandat sont toujours très
durs pour un président au
pouvoir, et le contexte actuel
complique les choses pour
Joe Biden.
- Absolument, vous savez cette
élection de mes mandats c'est un
peu un référendum sur la
présidence de Joe Biden.
L'inflation, on part du coût de
la vie qui a augmenté de plus de
8 %. C'est le loyer, c'est la
nourriture. Et ce que Joe Biden
espère c'est que les Américains
vont voter sur la question de
l'avortement,
il espère que le vote démocrate
va sortir. C'est, la majorité
des
Américains sont pour le droit à
l'avortement et le défi dededede
sortir le vote démocrate.
- Ce qu'il y a de plus
inquiétant c'est que dans 48 des
50 états il y a des républicains
qui ne reconnaissent pas la
victoire de Joe Biden à
l'élection de 20????
- 2020.
- Oui de 2020.
- On est l'de nouveaux
sénateurs, on réalise des
représentants à la chambre mais
aussi deerererernements et des
secrétaires d'État.
Ce ss postes clés quand il
y a des élections
présidentielles ce sont des
personnes qui vont compter les
votes et quand il va y en avoir
un vote serré, c'est qui vont
penser. En Arizona par exemple,
la candidate républicaine ne
reconnaît pas l'résultats des
élections de 2020.
Le secrétaire d'État, le
candidat républicain à un autre
qui dans un groupe, ont tenté de
prendre d'assaut le capital.
C'est les résu